what kind of thrills do you get in life  is it jumping out of perfectly good  airplanes is it rock climbing [ __ ] in  New York City at a time when it was  quite dangerous who 2,000 homicides a  year streets were dangerous and so I  felt the risk of death every day I  walked out I don't I don't take risks  unless I have talent in the thing that  might be risky for someone else to do so  then when I see people  hey let's go jump out of airplanes with  parachutes I'm saying why oh because  it's thrilling and it's fun and it's  risky and I'm thinking I risk I have  risks every day for an expert rock  climber and you're climbing Russia so  that's risky not for an expert of all  the ways that might die my parachute not  opening will not be one of them okay put  check in that box  not happening no no of all the ways I  might die freezing to death in a  mountain crevasse is not one of them of  all the ways I might die falling off a  cliff face will not be one of them  that's for sure  you